welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's session on
pioneering our understanding of the
human brain I'd like to introduce dr.
Teresa Cruz she is a health scientist
administrator who manages grants in the
devices and technology development and
rehabilitation diagnostics and
interventions programs at the National
Institute for medical rehabilitation and
research within the National Institute
for Child Health and Human Development
dr. crews will be replacing dr. Nick
Lionel's our original presenter can
begin the track on innovative new
technologies she will be presenting on
NIH funding for technology development
and translations to humans my name is
dr. Rebecca Shannon and I will be your
moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring this
educational web seminar presented by
legumes we would like to extend our
special thanks to the brain initiative
program directors in particular dr.
James mad for their efforts in
organizing today's session before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting your questions during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions in
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions by an email
following the presentation this
presentation is educational and this
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
grants tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window and
all the process to obtain your credits
now without further ado please join me
in welcoming dr. Teresa Cruz hello thank
you for the invitation to speak today
about NIH funding opportunities for
technology development for translation
to humans again my name is Teresa Cruz
and I'm a program officer at the NIH
earlier in this
conference you heard a description of
the brain initiative from a couple of my
colleagues so I'm not going to talk
about the whole of brain initiative now
but I would like to bring your attention
to our device funding pipeline at the
early stage we have a new concepts RFA
and this is really for early stage ideas
where you don't even have preliminary
data yet but you're looking at
developing technologies for invasive
recording and stimulation of the central
nervous system and this is an r21 we
move down the pipeline to the ro1
mechanism which is what we refer to as
our new tools RFA and this allows for
larger applications
larger budgets to really test out those
new ideas from the r21 in in vivo
settings
following on our new technologies ro1 we
have the brain device optimization uo1
which is a cooperative agreement and
here we're really thinking about how do
we get these new technologies into the
hands of the neuroscience community and
what do we need to do to get that
technology to be ready for use in labs
or in some cases in human subjects these
three do not require that the ultimate
user be a clinical clinical setting but
several of them are
the next part of the pipeline is for
human devices and here we have two
different flavors one is a phased award
and there's two different types here and
then we have a direct clinical trial of
one
so to zoom in on these a little bit the
purpose here is to support development
optimization and translational
activities and small clinical studies
involving therapeutic and diagnostic
devices for disorders that affect the
nervous system or the musculoskeletal
system
so for our phased awards this is the ug
3 and the uh3 or the SBIR u 44 phase 1
phase 2
combined FastTrack award and for these
RFA is there are some device development
that needs to occur and that's in the
either phase one for the fast-track SBIR
which is for small businesses or in the
ug three phase which is for academic
institutions and here you're going to be
doing your pre IDE studies your enabling
work for the FDA
after that's completed and an IRB has
been approved then you can move into the
early feasibility studies and our first
in human clinical trials
it's possible that a technology is ready
for that at this point and in that case
the applicant can go them directly into
the uh3 brain next-generation devices
RFA
so a couple things to note about these
funding opportunities for translation so
the first so that they're all
cooperative agreements there are not
grant mechanisms so that means that
there is significant involvement on the
behalf of NIH staff in the scientific
development and execution of these
awards
this is particularly related to the
milestone development so much of NIH
funds funding goes to hypothesis based
research or discovery driven research
these are different in that they are a
heavily milestone and they are device
development so there is a bit of a
difference here between traditional NIH
Awards you need to be working on
invasive tech devices you need to be
tapping into the central nervous system
which also includes the spinal cord and
the retina in addition to the brain
these are all considered clinical trials
so there is some intervention on behalf
of the device you may need to be
prepared with your clinical trial
information when you submit to NIH so
you cannot have a delayed onset and
there are some budget arrey requirements
these are typically larger budgets but
we do have caps particularly for the
small business awards we have due dates
three times a year and our next due date
is in June so
one of the nice things about this
translational program is that they many
of the applicants tap into the NIH brain
public-private partnership program this
is not required but we found that it's
been very helpful to many of our
applicants so this PPP program was
developed between NIH and several device
manufacturers and the hope was to
facilitate partnerships between the
individual investigators at academic
institutions and the device
manufacturers so in this program and I
encourage you to visit our website the
company's several of them are listed
here
provide technical support and
information about their neuro
stimulation devices
many of them have capabilities that are
beyond what is typically used in the
clinic NIH has also arranged for pre
negotiated agreement templates that can
help facilitate those relationships
between the investigator and the
manufacturer so each group doesn't have
to start from scratch when they work on
their
intellectual and material property
agreements
so now I'm going to give a few examples
of grants that have cooperative
agreements that have been funded through
the translational programs of the brain
initiative so the first is from AI
shotgun does and Kelly foot at the
University of Florida
they are working on a closed-loop
control of a central tremor treatment
this is a deep brain stimulation and in
the video that you'll see in just a
couple seconds you'll see a person who
been
who has the device installed and you'll
see that when the stimulator is off he
tremors quite considerably when the
stimulator is turned on you can see the
signal that goes into the DBS system to
turn on the stimulator and that signal
is indicative of the beginning of
movement so if you like to play that
video now
[Music]
you
okay so I hope you noticed
that this is an example of the
public-private partnership between
University of Florida and
Medtronic for the implanted stimulator
and of course the benefit of having a
closed loop control where the stimulator
is only turned on when the patient is
initiating movement is a preservation of
battery life and a reduction in
side-effects from having the DBS on
constantly so another example of the
translational program is from Phil troit
who is the PI
as part of a large group out of
iit and he and his colleagues are
working on a visual prosthetic and in
this case the
stimulation is
directed on to the
visual cortex so the signal comes in
through a camera it is processed and
then
wirelessly transmitted to the micro
electrode array which is
installed in the visual cortex they are
working on their pre ide work at the
moment in an animal model a canine model
and they hope to
recruit five human subjects for this
study as it proceeds and our third
example is from Greg Worrell at the Mayo
Clinic
he is also working in a canine model but
here they are working on an epilepsy
therapeutic platform whereby you can
measure oncoming seizures with implanted
EEG that gets processed
and then stimulation can be administered
in a closed-loop action to reduce the
focal epilepsy
again we are in k9 models but are
planning to move into
clinical trials in the upcoming grant
periods
it's just like to take a moment to
acknowledge another NIH initiative as
related to device development for
stimulation and recording of the central
nervous system and that is the heal
initiative which stands for helping and
addiction long-term there are many
facets to it but one of them is this
again device development pathway and
there are several opportunities
for applications to be submitted in
response to development of devices for
pain management and I would encourage
you to visit the NIH heal website to
look at those specific funding
opportunity
announcements so thank you for your time
today and enjoy your conference
thank you dr. Cruz for the informational
presentation as a reminder our speaker
will follow up with any questions about
her presentation by an email join us for
our next presentation in the innovative
neurotechnologies tract with our
presenters dr. Michael Gustav and dr.
John mcnutty who will present rathe our
analysis and visualization of
intracranial encephalography
enjoy - see you there